michael pour votre tour d'horizon des
résultats du week-end on commence par du
football direction maurepas je peux rien
vous cacher un grégory a less is more
pas à se rassure en difficulté dans le
championnat de première division de
district depuis le début de la saison
les à mort d'asia ont réussi à tenir en
échec à domicile le leader marly-le-roi
dans un match fermé
ce n'était pas du grand spectacle le
score un triste 0 à 0 l'écoutent les
réactions à la fin du match
points négatifs on marque quatre buts
point positif on n'en prend pas non plus
après dans le négatif on n'arrive pas
vraiment enchaîner des combinaisons on
n'arrive pas à faire cinq six sept
passes d'affilée donc difficile de se
créer des occasions difficile de deux de
progresser vers l'avant malgré cette
performance face au leader les mort pas
un restent neuvièmes du championnat six
longueurs du podium au repas tentera de
commencer une série dès ce dimanche 9
décembre les verts recevront le chesnais
troisième du championnat on espère
retrouver à maurepas en haut du
classement alors du basket pour
continuer michael une troisième victoire
consécutive pour l'entente le chesnay
versailles dans le championnat de
prénationale les yvelinois se sont
imposés à domicile contre le maccabi de
sarcelles sur le score de 89 à 80 un
match dominé de bout en bout malgré
quelques frayeurs en fin de match on
écoute les réactions en deuxième
mi-temps on est resté un petit peu sur
nos tirs extérieurs
on n'a pas assez varié le jeu ce qui a
fait que sans adresse bas sarcelles a
commencé à remonter
alors on avait prévenu les joueurs ça
allait être un match plutôt compliqué la
victoire est au bout c'est le principal
le match était un peu compliquée et donc
on a su être solides par moments il ya
des matches qui sont pas facile du tout
je préfère avoir des matches comme ça
tous les matches faciles
donc ça nous permet de travailler pour
continuer sa série de victoires
l'entente le chili versailles recevra ce
samedi 8 décembre paris basket à venir
une rencontre qui comptera pour le début
de la phase retour
bonne dynamique chez les garçons de
l'entente le chesnay versailles est ce
que les résultats sont aussi
satisfaisants pour les filles et ça va
très bien chez les filles également
l'équipe féminine du chesnay versailles
jouer dans le championnat de nationale 3
ce week end les yvelinois se sont
imposés 80 à 62 à l'extérieur sur le
terrain
passée une victoire qui permet aux
joueuses de conserver la première place
du classement après 9 journées disputées
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre gravenchonnais merci
michael pour ce tour d'horizon vous
retrouve dans un instant pour votre
émission le 7-8 fort